Trading it's a number game but it's also
very much a mental game.
I managed to beat the mental game of
trading.
>> When you see this the next step is
aggressive sellers.
>> Yeah.
you you coded the algorithm
>> up to the point where I was able to
achieve 500% return during 12 months in
the world most famous trading
competition also known as the robit cup.
So on top of mastering the psychological
game of you against the market, I was
able to do it with the pressure of the
world looking at me and thousands and
thousands of people commenting on every
up or down performance. In this video, I
will show you my mental models for a
successful trading.
Welcome back everyone to the channel. We
are going to go through the mental
models today and I will explain to you
my multi-layer problem solving approach
by explaining how the human psychology
work against us and give you some tips
on how to survive in these markets. This
documents that I prepared for you that I
will go through is called the ultimate
trader blueprint. And I want to start
with the nature of trading success, the
dual nature of trading success. And I
want to open the topic of consistent
profitability because to achieve
consistent profitability you don't need
to predict the markets and this is what
is widely misunderstood. You need to
switch to a concept of acceptance and
understanding of your edge and a concept
of probability not prediction. I will
explain this passage to you with two
perspective. The first one is the deeper
inner transformation. There is something
that goes beyond technical knowledge
because you can have the best edge in
the world but still lose money if you
don't have the mental model and risk
management model. So you need to start
with the concept of acceptance. You are
accepting to risk your money. You are
accepting that business is a difficult
profession. You are accepting that you
will only execute trades that have an
actual edge. You need to take
responsibility for your action. You
don't need to blame the market for your
errors. and you need to have consistent
practice and patience every day. The
second perspective is that trading is
not difficult. It's misunderstood and
you need to shift from a predictionbased
mindset to a probability based approach
following the law of large numbers and
achieving what is called expectancy and
performance. So let's go on and let's
understand how these two perspective
complement each other perfectly. I gave
you some real world example. There is
Michael an IT professional and he have a
tendency to overtrade. What does it mean
that Michael even if he have an edge he
didn't develop the inner discipline and
strategic framework to execute his
trades only when the opportunity
present. So he take more trades than
normal is overtrading. And when you
overtrade in your samples of data in 100
execution, maybe you have 30 trades that
follow the plan, but 70 trades that are
just created by your overtrading, they
are not in line with your blueprint,
your model. And this is the reason you
still can lose money if you don't have
the mental model to apply because you
don't have discipline. And so we go back
to the first perspective. Second one is
the time investment. Now let's say that
trading is not an easy skill in his
whole concept. The psychology
development can take one to two years of
consistent effort. It's like when we
talk about fitness, when we talk about
excelling in some professional field,
you cannot dream or think to do it in
one month or two months. You need
consistent practice and you need to
adapt your brain and your neurons to
this kind of discipline because we are
human beings. We will react to losing
money. We will go in revenge trading.
It's totally normal. It's not you that
is wrong. It's our brain. So let's go
back to the inner transformation and
let's go through the inner journey. So
the trader's inner journey starts with
five essential step. Awareness,
acceptance, responsibility and
consistent practice. Of course also
patience. We go to transformational
results after all these five are
achieved and we achieve emotional
control, rational decisions and
consistent profitability because there
is no consistent profitability if there
is not a level of discipline that it's
enough to execute an edge only when the
opportunity present itself. So success
requires more than technical knowledge
or marked strategy but requires a
paradigm shift. You need to go through a
probability approach, not a prediction
approach. Not what the market will do
tomorrow, but what's the result that I
can expect after 100 execution on my
trading account because this there is
this probability and this
risk-to-reward. So what I can expect is
this accounting for commission and loss.
This is trading. Going on to change your
results, you must first change yourself.
Remember that it's you that execute.
It's you that understand the
opportunity. It's you that frame the
risk management. We are not algorithmic
trader. We are discretionary trader. So
if you expect to have a different result
by putting the same input, it's just
impossible. You cannot change a recite
and the taste of a cake if the
ingredient are always the same. Just
impossible. The five step of inner
transformation go to the step one that
is awareness and step two that is
acceptance. The step one goes through
recognizing patterns identifying emotion
and stopping them immediately. Revenge,
anger against the market doesn't work
out. They do more damage than benefits.
Observe your behavior. Become the
psychology of yourself and trading
journal. And on the right side on the
step two, accept risk, accept losses,
accept uncertainty and give yourself the
ability to project a simulation to do
back test to achieve in the end the
foundation for emotional stability. Why?
Because you accepted risk. You are aware
of the risk and more than this you know
how much you can lose. Okay? You can
project it. So awareness as we saw is
recognizing pattern, identifying emotion
and observing behavior. And this phase
requires honestly with yourself and
ability to observe objectively. Don't be
afraid to blame yourself. If there is no
identification of the error, there is no
improvement. Here we have some practical
exercise. So is the benefit of
journaling your emotion. Also I gave you
two example. I can't miss this
opportunity. Fear of missing out. It's a
psychology condition or I need to
recover yesterday loss so today I risk
double I know that every one of you went
through this it's normal it's our brain
we are humans the phase two as I was
saying accept risk accept loss accepts
uncertainty and in this phase remember
that the trader develops a balanced
mindset but you need to understand that
trading is not a linear path to success
but a probabilistic activity with ups
and downs. Okay, here is the loss
simulation. If you want to go through
it, I will stop for 5 seconds so you can
take a screenshot. And the acceptant
paradox. What does it mean that if you
start by accepting that today you will
take a loss and you get in this mental
state, you will not overreact but if you
expect profit for today and you have a
loss for sure it will be guaranteed that
you will overreact overreact to this. So
going through the other three step
responsibility, practice and patience.
Step three is responsibility. Stop
blaming is not a fail of the market.
Make conscious decision. Understand what
you are doing and why. Take control of
your brain and take responsibility. Step
four practice. Have a daily routine. Do
journaling. Do visualization. Understand
what's your goal and have a morning
ritual. For me in this case is
meditation. I don't know if it's okay
for everyone. Maybe you are busy and you
cannot spare 20 minutes for this. But
get in a mental state where you are calm
before going on charts. Step five,
patience, gradual process, resist
impulsivity, trust the process and cost
opportunity calculator. Understand how
much the market is rewarding you for the
risk that you are inputting. This is the
framework for a complete inner
transformation. Step three,
responsibility. Stop blaming. Conscious
decision. take control. In this case, I
gave you an example of the
responsibility reframe exercise. I enter
without confirming the trend on higher
time frame. This is not failure of the
market. Stop blaming. This is you not
respecting the plan that you created,
validated and and came out an edge from
it. So you are just deciding consciously
to not respect your plan. This is not a
problem of the plan. This is not a
problem of the market. This is lack of
discipline. You cannot wait for the
correct opportunity to show. Consistent
practice. We went through it.
Journaling, visualization, routine and
ritual. Now let's talk about consistency
threshold. How much time it requires for
the mental brain to build an habit. It's
around 66 days. If you can achieve 66
days of discipline, journaling,
visualization, pre-planning of the
session, respecting your plan, you can
be a trader. If you cannot even complete
two months doing this, the probability
that you will lose as a trader is huge.
If not in the short run, in the long
run, we go to the last one. Patience,
gradual process, impulsivity, trust in
the process. Understand what you are
doing. Okay. Going on the opportunity
calculator is the cost of impulsive
trading. What does it mean? How much
does it cost to me an error? If I decide
to break the plan, no, don't follow it.
How much money can I lose? Three losses
out of the plan, maybe with one hour of
€1,000 or €3,000 or dollars that I lose
in the days that I don't follow the
plan. Are you able to sustain it?
Understand that every time you want to
untick this part of the checklist of the
plan, you are taking this risk. Ask
yourself if you are willing to go
through it. on this part on the
responsibility I show you this this
image of the mirrors because it's always
you versus you it's you that take
decision you try to blame today is the
failure of the markets today the
condition was not good the strategy
don't work but it's always you in the
center it's you that take decision okay
you need to identify the problem and fix
it because if you let the crack go
through your discipline each day will
sum up to the next and the bridge will
fall and the bridge is your trading
capital. This part of acceptance and
awareness it's amazing and I want to
create a metaphor with the Japanese
concept of putting together back the
piece of broken stuff with gold. Why?
Because everything that you can analyze,
understand and improve is something that
will be better. So you cannot improve
what you cannot journal. In this case
the months necessary 66 days because
there is no shortcut for for practice.
So you need a quant. Okay. And the
result that you can expect of the inner
transformation are the following.
Emotional control. You will be calm
during losses. You will be stable during
wins. You will not get euphoria because
you don't know how you made profit. You
think you are lucky. You will have
reduced stress. On the rational decision
you will be data driven. You will not
execute anything that is not in line
with your plan. You will have an
objective evaluation of what you're
doing and you will have a strategic
thinking. This merged together is what
is called consistent profitability.
Okay, you cannot remove emotions. We are
humans but you can control the reaction
that you have. Okay, so here is a
summary of emotional control, rational
decision and consistent profitability
and also life transformation. So going
beyond trading because personal growth
is required by trading is the catalyst
for a better life and this is the
spillover effect I like to call it like
this. It means that when you improve
your discipline, you improve your habit,
you improve your decision- making
process, you will see that not only your
performance in trading improve but your
life at 360 degree. This is something
that is a side benefit of trading. Let's
go on and let's go on the part where
trading is not hard but is misunderstood
because this is the trading reality and
most traders act like they will randomly
stumble into profit. Maybe today it will
be a lucky week. Please sir give me the
strategy that will change my life. They
forget the problem. The problem is the
trader not the strategy. And the
solution is a process over prediction.
Stop asking in discord channel what do
you think euros USD will do tomorrow how
will be gold next week please sir tell
me I want to get rich okay you need a
psychological foundation and
implementation path to get a strategic
framework this is the only path to
consistent profitability you cannot skip
it by just saying give me a profitable
model I will be a profitable traders
they did this test in Wall Street giving
to 100 people the same strategy and they
performed differently because it's
called discretionary trader because
there is discretion
You are yourself the strategy. It's not
some different entity. You the trader,
the discretionary trader are part of the
strategy, are part of the performance.
You have a direct impact on the profit
and loss of every month of trading.
Let's go on. So, isn't that trading is
hard, but rather that it's fundamentally
misunderstood by most people who attempt
it. So, going to the trading journey.
Common misconception about trading.
Success comes from finding the perfect
strategy. The holy grail or trading is
about predicting the future. The reality
trading is probability. Focus on process
not outcomes. Manage risk not
prediction. If I should give uh an
explanation of what's trading in simple
words trading profitable trading is
consistent execution of positive
expectancy. And this is how you feel at
the moment. You feel lost because there
are a lot of influencer in the trading
space that send you to multiple
direction without explaining you this.
You need to have an edge. You need to
have a mental model to apply it and you
need to have a correct risk management.
There is nothing more. This is trading
and this is the fundamental
misconception. You are trying to put
together a puzzle with the wrong pieces.
Of course, it don't work. Of course, you
are not profitable after years of
testing. So there is no perfect strategy
or indicator. There is no holy grail.
And there is no predictionbased system.
There is low or large number positive
expectancy and edge also called alpha.
This is something funny that I wanted to
put you here. The strategy hopper
journey. Have you ever been in this
situation where you consistently change
strategy day by day, week by week as
soon as the strategy goes in draw down
without understanding that every edge
sooner or later will go in draw down?
It's normal. So the common trading
mistakes is strategy hoping jumping from
one model to the other one having
unrealisting expectation. I want to get
rich with €1,000. You will not do it.
Not in the short term. Maybe if you if
you use this money to build an edge, to
refine it and get capital, you can, but
you will not get rich in the short term.
You have to put too much risk on the
table to make something reasonable with
a small amount of money. So your risk of
ruin goes to the moon. You don't need to
overmpathize on entry. Focusing too much
on entry points and forget about risk
management. Take a one shot. You know
how a lot of people do challenge. I will
take the best shot and that's it. I took
2,000 execution all with the same risk.
Emotional trading making decision based
on fear, greed or other emotion. This is
always wrong. Always. There is no case
where this kind of trading is
profitable. Psychological foundation
gave you this crazy scientist here with
all the emotions and going through the
psychology. We go back to the emotional
control, acceptance and responsibility.
You need to own your result. You need to
embrace uncertainty. You need to manage
your fear and greed. And in the concept
of psychological capital management, you
need to have consistent decision under
pressure. You cannot change your
decision only because you are going
through pressure. This is the summary of
how emotional control work and you need
to have a psychological circuit breaker.
What does it mean that you need to have
a way to interrupt the emotional
escalation? I will give you an example
of this. You are doing a prop firm.
Okay? You are really close to the max
draw down. You lose one trade. You
decide to increase the risk of the next
one to recover this one because you are
afraid of reaching the max loss. You are
breaching the emotional balance. You are
going to escalation. You need a way to
stop it. So quit breaker. It can be a
maximum draw down per day. It can be
done directly from the platform. If I
reach 1% of draw down, I stop for the
day. It can also be the best opportunity
the next one on the planet. I will not
take it because I'm not in a mental
state that let me trade successfully.
Okay, this is the summary of this part
that I just explained to you. So you
need responsibility. You need to avoid
blaming external factor, the market, the
news, power, Trump. It's not their
problem. Just understand that you need
to control what you can control.
Recognize that the results come from
your decision. Be proactive. Don't be
passive. Is not the word against you.
may constitute decision and take
ownership of the learning process. Okay.
Now going on psychological capital
account. We have a limited psychological
capital account. That is the capacity to
make clear decision under pressure. So
don't take if you are a beginner 10
execution per day. Start with short
execution and low number of execution.
Don't try to take 20 execution per day.
It requires a lot of discipline created
for you. this amazing image strategic
framework on every piece of the
chessboard. How you need to move, how
you need to think, you need to have a
perspective approach. You need to watch
the table from the outside understanding
that when you are moving a wrong piece,
when your emotion goes wrong, you cannot
continue. You need to wait patiently. So
the strategic framework goes through
risk management, consistency and testing
and validation accordingly. Position
sizing, process execution, back testing
and forward testing. Are you really able
to do profit? Do you have an alpha? Do
you have an edge? If no, study positive
expectancy system, edge, risk-to-reward
and sustainable trading performance.
This is the blueprint, the only
blueprint that you will find also by
yourself if you will trade for long
enough year and you will understand that
this mental model is the only one that
will make you survive in this market.
going on on the risk management side.
You need to have a clear position sizing
to have an appropriate stop-loss to have
an appropriate risk-to-reward and to
have a lower portfolio exposure that is
sustainable. Okay. Create your own
portfolio size calculators or if you
have a professional platform use
directly in the platform but make sure
that every execution have the same
amount of money of risk. Don't put more
risk only because you think this is this
will be a good trade because I already
took a three stop loss. The next one
will be a good trade. This is the best
way to go bankrupt. Okay. On the testing
and validation, you need to have an edge
that is test. You need to have a
detailed record to evaluate performance.
What time of the day trade? What trigger
you use. Why? Because in the long term
you can filter. You can understand you
know that London session is not worth to
trade for me. My profit factor is really
low. I pay a lot of commission but
profit factor is really low. What's my
benefit? I get half of the day for free.
I can go around. I can spend time with
my family and still having around the
same results. It will be worth it. No,
everyone is searching for more free
time. But when it's about trading, you
always want to stay in front of charts.
The first period of your trading will be
like this. Time will go on, but you will
need to get momentum. On the other side
of the mountain, downhill, it's easier
because your results start compounding.
Okay. with Newton law. So the ball start
to go around and you don't need to push
itself anymore. It's the ball that is
pushing you. Implementation path. How
can we go from theory to practice?
Create a trading plan. Create a daily
practice and review the process. You you
need to have rules and guidelines. You
need to have a routine and journaling.
You need to have an analysis a process
of analysis. Bridging the implementation
gap. System over willpower have rules.
It's really difficult to be disciplined
if you don't have rules and have a
gradual position scaling. Okay, if
you're going good, scale when the market
is giving you the ability to do it. You
made a lot of profit for the week, for
the month. You can increase the risk if
you want accordingly to the amount of
profit. Don't risk all your profit
because otherwise you are just putting
at risk everything you already made.
Consistent execution in real market.
This is the framework going on on the
trading plan. You need entry indexit
rules. You need risk parameters. You
need favorable market condition. And you
need the procedure to handle various
trading scenarios. For example, my trend
following strategy don't perform really
good in consolidation market. That's the
reason I need to understand before how
the market will behave in the session.
You can do this with multiple parameters
like ATR or open session behavior to
understand how much the session will
have in average movement and you need to
have daily practice, you need to have a
journal, you need to have visualization
and you need to have practice trading
skills. So going through result and
evolution, the trading mastery outcomes
goes through consistent profitability,
psychological growth, adaptability,
continuous evolution, market adaptation,
strategy refinement, and life
integration because you need to change
your life. The evolution paradox.